the Joe Rogan experience Anthony
Bourdain used to get really angry about
this and one of the things that he said
was this is a first world problem he's
like we are so fortunate with that we
have this problem and in other countries
they're just trying to get enough
protein to feed their family they're
just trying to get enough food to feed
people you know and he was it wasn't
like he was indifferent to animals but
he was deeply concerned about people
yeah you know because of all this is
traveling he had like a great deal of
empathy for all these different people
in these different cultures and their
cuisine and they did a tremendous amount
of respect for it like he would talk
about it like it was religious to him
almost you know yeah like you know when
we would go into villages and eat I mean
if they if they had meat like that was a
big deal like if they if they brought
meat out to you then they you know that
was a huge deal yeah I mean you look at
it and it's just like gosh you know we
you know world beer complain about stuff
that that most countries wish they had
those problems like almost 90% of stuff
we're complaining about most countries
wish they had those problems right but I
get it the people don't want those
problems to exist to they want those
problems to go where they want to utopia
and the only way to build towards utopia
is to improve upon the problems that we
have and we do have problems across the
board but incomparably just I would just
love some perspective from people I
would just love some and I think that
would go a long way to help people have
more happiness let me but I mean how do
you wake up when all you do is focus on
problems right like it's kind of like
you know when you're when you're working
or you're at a job right or you own a
company like everybody's you're always
just fixing I call it putting out fires
yeah and if that's all you do is
constantly put out fires like at what
point do you become grateful like like
at what point at what point of the day
do people stop and look around right and
they're grateful for what they have and
they're appreciative of I had a guy
telling me you know when I was going
through my divorce I mean I was I was a
train wreck just called Tim Kennedy and
he'll tell you you know I'll never
forget a guy set me down I was talking
about all these problems and just nip I
mean just nitpicking and fighting over
the small stuff and I mean literally
just well she worded it this way and she
needs to do it this way like literally
just every little thing and a guy
finally sat me down he looked
he goes look Dakota he said if you can
make choices or decisions to change it
then it's not a problem it's an
inconvenience today that you can't make
a choice you've got cancer your kids
sick or something like that he goes
that's a day you got problems until then
you just got inconveniences that's a
great way to look at it until then you
just got inconveniences and I was like
you're right it's a great way to look at
it because there's levels of problems
right there's insurmountable problems
cancer injuries things things of that
nature car accidents car mountable you
know what and the thing is I think you
know the I think I'm so fortunate to
have gone through the experiences that I
have because I you know each one of them
it it's all perspective it changes my
perspective on the way I look at things
it changes the things that are important
to me I call it I always call it
everybody's got their lens of life and
that lens a life you know your lens of
life looks different than mine mine
looks different than yours and at all we
all have our own lens life and at the
point you know we get so focused and get
into autopilot and it'll focus on you
know it's kind like your camera you pull
it up and you got on autofocus it never
focuses on what you want it focused on
right until you go back to the manual
focus and you push where it's at and I
feel like all these problems that we
have are just made - hey we need to
tighten our lens back up to focus on
what really really really matters
[Applause]